d'abord donc le point sur cette enquête
à la courneuve 24 heures après la mort
d'un enfant sidi ahmed et l'élève de cm2
tué par balle alors qu'il lavait la
voiture de son père est bien un homme
est recherché ce soir par la police il
aurait été aperçu
reconnu par des témoins nicolas sarkozy
s'est rendu sur place dans une ambiance
surchauffée in boudaoud de monique
bonnet son discours est rodé mais
nicolas sarkozy a dû mouiller sa chemise
pour convaincre les jeunes de la
courneuve et ce ne fut pas facile
ces points je suis là pour vous aider
dans les sondages c'est comme ça c'est
loin de fois invité ses bad le board et
moi voulait collaborer collaboraient
déjà amélioré les conditions
le ministre de l'intérieur est venu
présenter ses condoléances aux proches
du petit sid-ahmed tué hier au pied de
son immeuble
cette visite n'a pas plu à tout le monde
en particulier aux professeurs de
l'enfant décédé
moi comme sarkozy vienne ce soir entouré
de toutes ces caméras
si c'est ça être près du peuple prix du
peuple à la télé n'est pas dans la
réalité
pourtant la démarche de nicolas sarkozy
a été apprécié par la famille de la
jeune victime
si nous avons empêchés de nous a
présenté les condoléances et l'a promis
qui mettra tout l'effectif nécessaire
ce soit un humain ou énoncé point qu'il
est coupable
les coupables la police pense les avoir
identifiés elle tenterait même d'obtenir
de l'auteur des coups de feu mortel
qu'ils se rendent
si la mède aurait été la victime
malheureuse d'un règlement de compte qui
ne le concernait pas entre deux familles
de la cité
d'abord on va arrêter les auteurs ses
assesseurs quel que soit leur âge et
leur situation
c'est à mon sens une ferveur la deuxième
chose c'est que les habitants de la cité
des cas puis long comme les autres
habitants de france le droit à la
sécurité
on va donc nettoyé au propre comme au
figuré la cité des 4000
alors dès demain le ministre l'a annoncé
une opération de police devrait être
mené à la courneuve une façon sans doute
de rassurer une population en état de
choc après la mort de sid-ahmed oui la
mort 2